(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
You know, as we approach
the thanksgiving season,
the holiday season,
I'm just grateful to be able
to continue to have these conversations,
'cause I know these things
are really important.
The holidays is obviously a time
which I take time and really enjoy
the company of our family and friends,
but can also be a challenging
time in a lot of ways.
And so I think today,
the fact that we're
having this conversation
about support and advocacy and resources,
is really timely in that sense.
And I'm grateful for the two guests
who are joining me today,
this is their first time
actually interacting,
but I already have great chemistry,
as I noticed offline
before we even jumped in,
I anticipate there'll be staying in touch
after this as well.
So the first guests I'd like to introduce
is Matt Kudish.
Matt is the Executive Director
of a National Alliance on Mental Illness
in New York city.
And NAMI NYC is actually
one of the largest
affiliates of NAMI in the country,
helping support families and individuals
affected by mental illness
and to also build better lives
through education, support and advocacy.
Matt is someone who has been named
to city and state's
health empower list
for the last three years.
So, he's obviously recognized
for his leadership and expertise.
He's also the recipient of the Beatrice
and Goldberg Community Award
by the West Side Inter-Agency
Council for The Aging
and also The Emerging
Social Work Leadership Award
from the National
Association of Social Workers
in New York City as well.
He has a Master's in
Social Work from Columbia.
He also has a Master's
in Public Administration from MIU
and he's a Fellow and the
Inaugural Strell Fellowship
Executive Leadership
Program at Hunter College.
So someone who obviously is very busy
and very skilled in his craft
and we're grateful to welcome Matt
to the Addy Hour podcast today,
thanks for being here.
- It's a pleasure.
- My second guest that
I'd like to introduce,
is Corey Minor Smith,
who is an Attorney
and the author of "#Driven"
also the founder of Corey Empowers
and the Driven U Community.
She's someone who has navigated
the Mental Health Care Services industry
for over 25 years
based on her family's story,
which I know she'll share about
likely today as well.
But she's also earned a Master's
in Education, Guidance and Counseling,
and is a Trained Facilitator for NAMI.
So you can see some of
the overlap already,
so I'm grateful we were able
to make this pairing work.
And people also know
Corey as a thought leader
in the social justice space
with a primary focus on
mental wellness advocacy.
As I mentioned in 2019,
she released her and now
highly celebrated debut book,
"#Driven" with a foreward
by renowned motivational
speaker Les Brown.
She also has been involved
in several different interviews,
has appeared on several platforms
in the National Media Space,
on talk shows,
on the Audible Original, We've Got Answers
and on radio shows like
The Breakfast Club.
she's also been recruited
by different fortune 500 companies
to actually talk about
leadership development
and the importance of incorporating
strong and the relevant mental health care
in those conversations.
So again, grateful to welcome,
Attorney Corey Minor
Smith to the Addy Hour.
- Thank you for having me,
it's my pleasure to join you today.
- Pleasure having both of you here.
And obviously there's
so much important work
that you both do in terms of advocacy
and just in your day to day endeavors.
So, as my listeners know,
I do like to check in
and see how people are doing,
especially with,
some of the heavy topics
that you all are engaged in
on the daily basis as well.
So we want to start there
and just see how you're doing
today of all days and just,
in our ongoing changing
societal situation as it were.
So Matt, why don't we go
ahead and start with you?
- Yeah, I appreciate the question too,
'cause I think we don't know
what's going on for folks
in the midst of these 20 months.
And I think I learned
early on in the pandemic
that I didn't know how I
was gonna feel each day
until my feet hit the floor
in the morning when I got up.
So today I'm feeling really excited,
energized, and hopeful.
And also at the same time,
balance that with thinking about
what these next few months and winter
is gonna bring both as it relates
to social isolation
and really being a part again
and pandemic surges.
But I'm balancing that
keeping that in my mind
while also at the same time,
feeling really grateful and excited.
- That's great.
And in a sense,
also just appreciate the way
that you talked about that
even in your rotation and in your role,
I think it's helpful for people to realize
that even those who are
serving in organizations,
who are in the mental health space
doesn't mean that you have
all the answers all the times.
I mean, as you talked about
just not knowing how you'd feel
on a specific day and to
give yourself permission
to have that unknown in a sense,
I think is really important.
- Yeah.
- Corey, what about you?
How are you at this moment?
- Well, I say ditto,
Matt covered it all.
It's very important for us
to take the time to think about ourselves
when we help people,
other people on a daily basis sometimes,
we forget or perhaps
just don't make ourselves a priority
and it's important to do that.
And for me right now, just grateful,
not just because it's November
and we're going into thanksgiving,
but just overall grateful
for safety and good health,
battling a little cold,
but that's nothing in comparison
to other things that
are going on right now.
And so, I'm just grateful
and appreciate the opportunity
to continue to share
with social isolation,
by having Zooms and things
that can keep us safe,
but just understanding that it's important
to still do the work,
but we have to make sure
that we are keeping ourselves energized
and healthy in order to
continue to do the work.
- That's so well said and so important.
I appreciate the way
that you all are bringing
just these, I mean, the perspectives,
the gratefulness kind of
the reality of the unknown.
I think that that's just healthy
for us to be able to have,
even these types of conversation.
As leaders to say, okay,
there are things we can look back
and be grateful for,
but there are also things that we
know are still challenging even as we have
that attitude of
gratefulness moving forward.
So definitely appreciate
the standard and the example
that you all are living too.
And I know that doesn't mean it's easy.
- Oh absolutely not.
But you know that going in.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I think, the pandemic really
kind of shined a light
on how easy it is to forget,
how difficult it can be.
I consider myself
to be a pretty resilient individual
and the struggle has been real
and really up and down,
despite feeling incredibly grateful
and fortunate, I've had my health,
I have not had COVID-19,
I'm lucky enough to be in a safe house
and have access to everything that I need.
And this pandemic really forced me
to kind of dig deeper and say,
well, if I'm struggling
and I see myself as pretty resilient,
what must this be like for everyone?
And I think a lot of times,
we hear people talk about
that we're all in the same
boat going through this.
And I think we're all
experiencing coronavirus
at the same time,
but our boats look really different.
Some of us are on a super yacht,
some of us are on a raft
that's falling apart,
some of us are by ourselves, in a kayak,
some of us are with
friends on a speed boat.
I mean, we're all on the riding
the Corona river as it were.
But the journey is very different,
and I'm so grateful for that perspective
because I didn't see it
really in that same way
prior to all this happening.
- I think that's saying a lot.
I appreciate that honesty as well,
because even in your position,
as someone who thinks about these topics,
often even things that
you're also learning
and seeing as we're going
through the pandemic as well.
Corey, I wonder if in your work,
as you've been involved
in advocacy as well,
have you seen any shifts
as we've kind of hit the pandemic
as we try to think about mental health?
Obviously there's been more
attention as Matt mentioned
to the mental health piece,
but any shifts that you've noticed?
- Yes, surely an increase indeed.
And that's why I'm very grateful
for organizations like NAMI,
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
that have transitioned with
our world transitioning
and having these opportunities
for virtual classes, virtual seminars,
virtual trainings,
because mental illness
or mental health conditions do not stop
because everything else
in our world has stopped
and people need the services
and their medication
and their support systems, the act team,
anyone has the acting
assertive community treatment
teams that come out and help.
This pandemic doesn't stop those needs.
And I'm really grateful for organizations
that found a way to continue
to keep their employees safe
and provide the services
to individuals that need it.
And that's for those who already
were established with the services.
What we see now are people
trying to deal with,
grappling with their feelings
and emotions and losing their job
or losing family members.
And they don't know how to
deal with their emotions
and how they're feeling
and may not know about
any of these organizations
and using them for the first time,
like Food Banks.
But being grateful that
these things are here
and maybe they don't
want to have to use them,
but they know it's there
and they can use them without shame.
So I think it's very important
that as we see this increase,
we know there was already a need.
And then that helps us as advocates
to continue to advocate
for more services,
more funding, more treatment,
because it doesn't stop,
if anything, it's going to increase.
- Yeah, yeah, I think
you're exactly right.
And I love how you pointed,
paying that as kind of two different
fore signs in a sense,
really pointing people to
the resources are there,
but also making sure more resources
are available in that way as well.
And that's a helpful segue as well.
'Cause Max I was gonna have you
just actually talk a little bit about,
how you got into this work
and what actual services NAMI provides
for any who may not be familiar
only vaguely familiar
with some of the work that you all do.
- Yeah, so I've been
with NAMI New York city
for a little over four years.
And prior to that,
I worked with older adults
and their caregivers
with a focus on Alzheimer's disease
and other neurocognitive disorders.
So I worked in aging for about 15 years
and then the opportunity came
to move to NAMI NYC and people would say,
oh, why, you know, you've been doing,
working in aging for so long,
why are you doing this 180
and going into this whole other space?
And it really isn't a 180,
there's so much more in
common with Alzheimer's,
especially it's not a mental illness,
but the stigma is profound.
The shame that it brings to families
is just as powerful.
The ability for the person
who is living with the illness
to participate and play an active role
in their wellness,
their recovery, their wellbeing,
is meaningfully impacted by each of these
and the impact on families
and caregivers and
communities more generally
is really similar.
And so what I found at NAMI NYC
that's so special
is that we are a peer organization.
So the mental health space
is a really crowded space
and organizations like ours
that are focused on individuals
with lived experience,
both people living with
mental health issues
and family members, friends,
and other supporters,
coming together to share
their personal experiences,
their journeys,
the validation that they can share
from understanding what
you're going through
because they are living it as well.
It's outside the treatment modality.
So, but it also compliments
what we do this peer support model
is complimentary to every one of those
more traditional treatment
kinds of intervention.
So, you can go to therapy once a week,
you can be served by an act team.
You can in a clubhouse program
and still come to NAMI NYC,
get support, get
connected, find community,
and a sense of belonging,
which can be really difficult.
I think so often when
people are struggling
with mental health issues,
they and their family members,
feel so isolated and alone.
And we're here, we've lived it,
we are living it.
And when you walk through our door
or you pop into one of
our virtual sessions,
you're welcomed and you see
that the playing field is level,
that there's really a safety
and a nonjudgmental approach
to the work we do.
For us things really
start with our helpline,
it's available Monday through Friday
from 10:00 AM to 6:00 PM.
It's the primary way that
folks first connect with us.
I like to say, you don't need to know
what questions to ask,
just call and our helpline responders
can help you figure out what's going on
and the best way to kind
of navigate your situation.
I think we have to remember,
and if you've met one
person who's living with
or affected by mental illness,
you've met one person.
These are not easy situations to solve
with a one size fits all approach,
it's very individualized
and person centered.
And so we'd like to start where people are
and connect them both internally
to our full array of
programs and services,
all of which are available free of charge
and also connect them
to very specific, meaningful resources
that may exist outside of our walls.
So we keep a really
robust resource directory
of over 500 entries of programs
and services and resources
within the New York city area
for different community members,
for diverse communities,
for different kinds of needs,
whether it's legal assistance or housing
or any other employment,
anything that you can think of
really intersecting with us.
We wanna be a trusted resource
of people who understand and get it
because of that lived experience.
And from the helpline
that really kicks off
to evidence-based education classes.
We have over 30 support groups
that take place every single month.
We do a lot of stigma reduction work,
we go into schools
and community centers and companies.
And we do a ton of advocacy
and we're recruiting folks
to lend their voices to these issues,
and these causes, to help shine a light
on how many of us are affected.
We say, one out of five of us
is living with mental illness
while the other four are
their family members,
their friends, their colleagues at work,
their social networks,
their next door neighbors.
So these issues really affect all of us.
And when we find a way to talk about
what we're going through,
we realize we're not alone.
We realize we are part of a community
that is deeply impacted in these ways
that other people can really understand,
appreciate and validate.
- That's so good, I mean,
it's such an array of just opportunities.
And I love the framing too.
That sounds like a lot of ways,
it's an entry point.
The fact that you're saying
people don't need to know what to ask,
I think is powerful.
'Cause I think sometimes
there can be a hesitation,
not knowing what to ask, even if it's,
someone that you know, who's struggling
or someone, you may be
struggling yourself,
not knowing where to start,
but to be able to have
that level of openness,
to try and figure out
what to ask the first place,
then to be able to be plugged
into all the different
resources and programs
that you all have
and you connect other people with too,
I think that's really powerful
and we definitely need more of it.
- Yeah, and I think
being treatment adjacent
and having as wider front door as we can,
with as few barriers as possible
and really being of the communities
that we're connecting and serving,
allows us to create a space
where you don't have to know the answers,
you don't have to.
We just want you to call,
we just want you to come,
just connect with us to recognize
that this is a journey.
These are marathons, not sprints.
And anything we can do
to provide that kind of support.
I think sometimes we
live in a world today,
where it's a little
dangerous to make mistakes
in some ways to say the wrong thing
or to use the wrong word.
And we wanna create a space where people
can feel vulnerable and safe,
exploring these issues
to figure it out
because they're so complex
and there's so much nuance
and it's so individualized
that I don't want
anybody to feel the shame
that they can't sort of
discover what's going on,
discover on this journey
of how to help someone,
how to help yourself
while you're helping someone.
So we really try to just be
as open as we possibly can.
- Yeah, and I really love that.
I mean, the way that
you're inviting people in,
'cause it's tough already.
So, that piece is huge
to be able to have that
openness and invitation
to really include so many folks
in so many ways.
Corey, to pivot to you,
I know you've also been involved in NAMI,
but then also have a bit of your own story
that you've been walking
through even before,
you got involved in the organization.
So I wonder if you could just tell us
a little bit about your
path into this work
and the ongoing work that
you're doing as well.
- Yeah, I heard you say walking through
and I feel like I was
thrown into this space,
and I had to figure it out,
like a fish out of water flapping around
because I was around 14 years old
when we had to take my mother
to the emergency room,
she was talking non-stop, incoherent.
She had the ideas of grandiose,
thinking that she had miraculous powers
and all of these things.
And so for me to hear that,
I did not know what was going on
and for me to not be
able to interact with her
because it was, I'm talking to her,
but she wasn't talking to me
and it was like, I wasn't there.
But a family member came
and we went to the emergency room
and that's when I heard the diagnosis
for the first time,
manic depression, paranoid schizophrenia.
And manic depression now known as,
bipolar disorder.
But still those were just words,
didn't know what that meant,
didn't know that that
would ultimately mean
that she wouldn't be the mother
that I thought that I had
or would have for the rest of my life,
but it was in the learning experience.
And so from that age of 14,
basically seeing my mother go in and out
of mental health institutions,
and by the time I went to college,
I just was trying to
learn all that I could.
And that my first education
piece, if you would,
is a television movie
called "Out Of Darkness",
that starred Diana Ross,
it came out in 1994.
But when I saw the previews,
I'm like, it looked very, very familiar
and I'm like, oh my gosh,
I need to watch this.
But I didn't know that
that was mental illness,
I didn't know that that was
some kind of way related
to my mother's diagnosis,
but as I continue to educate myself
and then getting a master's degree,
that wasn't because I
wanted it necessarily.
I wanted to learn more
about mental illness
and what my mom was going through.
And studying from the DSM-IV at that time,
the five is out now.
But that helped tremendously
and learning a bit more
and what could happen,
what was available for my mom's future,
as well as mine.
So with that,
once I started my career as a lawyer,
my aunt, my mother's sister,
who was very instrumental
in helping my mother as well.
She saw an article for
NAMI in the newspaper.
She clipped it out
and put it in my mailbox.
And she had a little note on it saying,
I think this is something
you should go to.
And it was the family, the family,
the course it was 12 weeks
at that time back in 2009.
And I went to it,
I think I was probably
the youngest person there,
the only person there
who was there because of a parent
with severe mental illness,
but all of our stories were
so similar, so similar.
And we learned a lot from each other
as well as the course.
And then as I continued in my career
and most of my last 10 years of my career
was in public housing.
And we provide housing for individuals
with disabilities and low
income families and seniors.
So dealing with reasonable accommodations
and other things that
are on the legal side
with giving me a whole nother aspect
of advocacy for individuals
who are living with severe mental illness.
Ultimately, I started
helping to raise money
for our local NAMI chapter
through the walks that we would have.
And I then wanted to get
trained and give back.
It was my way,
someone took time out to provide
these free services for me and my family
and other families,
and I wanted to be able to do the same.
So I did do the training.
I co-facilitated my first course,
and I also participated for the first time
and speaking to law enforcement
as a part of their in-service training
and sharing our lived experience
and helping them to have strict strategies
in place procedures,
in place for helping someone in crisis
and things that they can do
and working with the family.
So I think that's so important,
especially in the black community
and we have concerns
of calling the police.
We want help,
but you don't know if anybody
is gonna make it alive.
And those are realities
for us, unfortunately.
And I know I've had to call the police
a number of times on my mother
and today looking back on it, I feel fear,
but I'm grateful to God
that nothing ever happened to my mother
and that we had law enforcement officers
and, individuals from
community treatment teams
that helped even when
they didn't have to help.
I kind of feel like I had an
informal network of people
because they knew me,
they had my number, they could call me
and I could call them to try ultimately
to keep my mother safe.
Even when her behaviors
weren't so safe towards me.
- Yeah, that's so important.
I mean, there's so many just key pieces
that you just talked about.
I mean, from the legal aspect,
from what you've gone through
as a family member,
to just having that support
and having teams in place.
I think it's so encouraging to hear
the way that you have
walked it out in a sense,
and I know walking isn't,
not the best way to put it
because as you mentioned,
you were thrown into it.
But the fact that you've been able to
take that throwing and
turn it into a journey
that's really empowering so many people
I think is really
amazing in a lot of ways.
I know, having heard you
talk elsewhere before
that you definitely are a proponent
of the team approach
and how important that has been as well.
And I think that's a theme
that cuts through the work
that both of you do in terms of the,
these aren't things that
are done in isolation.
And a lot of ways, you're trying
to get folks out of that isolation
to make sure that there are ways
to really approach this as teams.
But I'm also curious
because both of you are so involved
in the work itself.
Do you think that permeates?
So, I mean, as we were talking about
before we came on,
and Matt, you mentioned as well,
one in five who are
dealing with mental illness
and the other four probably
know someone who is.
But then I feel like there's also
a difference between those
who are actively in the midst of it
and have all of these components
that you've talked about
and think about these things deeply
versus some who are in the
midst of it at the moment
and may have perspectives on the outside.
So when we talk about
how mental health is viewed as society,
do you feel like there's a difference
between those who are kind of in the midst
versus the general portrayal in society?
And if so, are we making progress
in actually improving that
and making those two a
little bit more aligned?
So I know that's a big question, but...
- From what I hear
and from what you're saying,
I really feel that those, any of us,
those who were in the work or not
we're part of the one in five we're apart,
'cause that's any mental illness.
Depression and that anything that causes,
and I'm not a clinician, I'm a lawyer,
but anything that causes heightened,
emotional, something,
like it could be good
stress or bad stress.
Planning a wedding,
that can be great,
but it's also stressful.
But it's a good stress, right?
Having a death or having issues at work
that could be like bad stress.
But depending on how it impacts you,
it can be from mild to severe.
It just would like depression.
So, you're not eating well,
you're not sleeping well,
whatever your symptoms may be.
And I feel like that is the one in five.
But severe mental illness,
one in 25 experience
severe mental illness.
And that's the biggest distinctions
that I recognize
and are the hallucinations,
delusions and anosognosia,
where the person doesn't even have
knowledge that they're sick.
And that can be very, very dangerous.
It's very, very difficult
because you try to communicate
with your loved one,
you see the behaviors,
they don't see the behaviors,
and it can just be very, very complicated.
But the biggest distinction for me,
for any mental illness
versus severe mental illness,
when you're dealing
with the hallucinations
and the delusions,
and anosognosia.
Any other thing that's impacting mentally
are things that we can perhaps have
outside treatment for.
We may not necessarily need medication,
or we may need to invoke more self care
and you be able to deal with it.
But self care alone is not gonna deal
with severe mental illness.
And so I just caution people as caregivers
because the statistics are alarming
for caregivers and their
own health declining
because of the stress and strain
of helping a whole nother person
and that person's life,
in addition to your own life,
work, children, family,
whatever your responsibilities are
and that of another person
and their hallucinations or delusions,
if you're dealing with
severe mental illness.
But even with depression,
if it may be in its most severe forms,
causes a lot of stress and strain
on the caregiver as well.
So with that,
I encourage people in whatever work
that they're doing,
that they implement,
what is good for them
in terms of self care.
That's not just going to the spa
and things of that nature,
but meditation.
And sometimes it's just chilling,
like just chill out,
take a seat somewhere and chill out.
- That is really well said.
Do you have other specific tools
that you've encouraged folks to use,
or even things that you've used yourself
over the years?
- Yes, like walking, sitting by water,
you can listen.
There's so many apps
that are available now
to like calm, Headspace,
different things like that.
But what I found and even counseling
and is because of my busy-ness,
I needed to combat down and be consistent.
For example, it took me three times
to go to counseling
and for me to commit to it.
Once when I was a child,
unfortunately my mother did attack me
and I was removed from the home
and so part of the court order
was for me to go to counseling,
I didn't like it.
I might've went to two or three sessions.
I share this because it's okay
if your first time doesn't work out,
you know, just try it again.
Maybe that counselor
and you don't jell, that's fine.
You don't have to go to just one.
Another time was when I was in law school
and I may have had like
mild depression then
based on the survey.
But all of my responsibility at that time,
you would think that,
you probably are stressed out,
it causes some level of depression.
I was a new mother,
my son was potty training
when I started law school.
New wife, commuting to law school
and law school in general was just hard.
So I did try it, but maybe one session,
I did not like it.
But the third time,
I'm still with her
today, has been about at least 10 years.
But what made it effective,
was when I made the commitment
to be consistent with my appointments
because of everything else I was doing,
counseling would be the
first thing I would cancel.
And I had to learn to
not operate at a crisis,
not to try to get an appointment
when I'm overwhelmed with
whatever I was dealing with in my life.
But just having it as a
constant on my schedule,
not canceling it and going.
- Yeah, and that's so important.
All those things that you brought out,
just in terms of,
it doesn't always work on the first time,
like you said,
having that persistence and willingness
to kind of make it a priority too,
which is also not easy and you're right,
I mean, people don't always jell.
So I think to your point,
people shouldn't be disappointed
if it doesn't work out the first time.
And people have to be in the right,
has to be the right combination.
This is in terms of personality
and all the different types of styles
of different therapists use.
So just being open to saying,
okay, that style,
that person might not
have been the right fit,
that doesn't mean we
throw it all out per se.
So your example, I think is great.
- I think it's like dating a little bit.
It's about that fit,
it's about that fit
and not everybody is gonna be
what you need in that moment.
And I also think that,
when you think about therapy,
it tends to be a white middle upper class
sort of construct
that other people from other cultures
and other diverse groups,
aren't used to going to a stranger
and talking about
what's going on inside of them,
that they've maybe never
said out loud before
to someone else.
So not only do we have
to help normalize that,
it's okay to talk with people
who are expert and trained
to help guide you through it,
which is hard to convince people.
Oh, we don't talk about
that stuff outside the family
or we got this, this is
our problem to solve,
thanks anyway.
But then you have to get people to realize
that it might not on that first try
and know how important
it is to find someone
who understands your experience.
So that when you're talking about
what's going on for you, they may not,
they don't have to have literally
experienced it themselves.
But if they don't understand the culture,
the context of where you're coming from,
it's gonna be a lot
harder to really feel like
you're obscene and heard in a way.
And you don't wanna have to explain,
like, I'm a gay man.
I don't wanna have to explain
what that means
to my straight therapist.
It's a different starting point,
and I think it's so important.
I know a lot of people said,
oh, I tried it once,
not for me therapy, not for me.
You gotta try it again,
I think it's really important.
Like Corey said,
it may not be that first shot
for whatever reason.
Maybe it's not the person,
maybe you're not ready for it,
but you gotta keep giving
it a shot if you can
I think, yeah.
- So well said.
And I really appreciate that,
in your role too, that
you're thinking about,
that cultural competency
life you talked about
so that people can
engage with you on that,
to know that if that's missing,
that's a huge component
that can really be, that's important
and needs to be part of it.
So the fact that you,
you are making that plain
and making it known,
I think it's really important as well.
Oh, go ahead.
- I was just gonna say
these differences matter.
They really make it,
it matters a lot.
After George Floyd was murdered,
we started a group
called Black Minds Matter
to create a space for people
who identify as black
and living with a mental health condition,
to come together
among those multiple levels
of shared experience.
And we heard from a
lot of people early on,
I've been waiting
for this kind of space to be here.
It's unfortunate,
for us it took the murder of George Floyd
for that to happen.
But since last summer,
it's really been a consistent,
ongoing source of support
where the people who attend
that group feel seen.
they are experiencing it.
When you talk about what
you're going through
and people are nodding along
because they get it, you feel,
you feel that,
you feel validated and
seen and normalized.
And it's similar to what Corey said about
being the only one in family to family
who was there for a parent,
dealing with a parent.
There's a lot of relate-ability around
having an ill relative,
but it's different when it's your parent
than it is if it's your spouse
or your adult child.
Those relationships matter,
it's the same thing
that all of those sort of data points,
we really wanna make sure
that there's connectivity among them
so that people are getting the most
out of the experience of support
and giving it too.
It goes in both directions
when you're in a group or a class,
you're sharing
and you're being shared with,
and the power of that is really
exponentially, I think increased
when you relate to the people around you,
when you feel seen
and you feel that that shared experience.
- Yeah, yeah, that's huge.
And I think it goes a long way in building
that level of trust too,
that's really important
and moving forward in a lot of ways.
Through the challenges,
'cause they are challenging.
If the trust isn't there,
I think it makes it that much harder
for people to really engage
and Corey it sounds like you all
had that in the group too.
Just the relate-ability there,
it seems like there
was some level of trust
that came with that as well,
because, oh, these are other people
who can relate to what I've been through
and we can trust each other
to learn from each other
about how to navigate it,
which I think is really important.
- And what I also found important
just in the community,
'cause some people don't
wanna identify with
how they know you in the community.
But once I guess,
whether it's like an eye contact
or it's okay, I wanna give you the,
'cause we know each other from NAMI.
You wanna make sure that you are
respecting people's privacy
and what they are willing to share
outside of the space,
that's important as well.
But it's great to still have connections
with people who went through the program.
- Yeah, that's great to hear
those continue as well.
And Matt that's encouraging.
Yeah, go ahead.
- I was just gonna say something
that goes back to the,
your question, Dr.Addy
around kind of the state of things now.
And Corey, as you were talking
about the distinction
between mental illness
and serious mental illness.
One of the things that
we've been talking a lot about,
these issues they're not binary,
it's not all or nothing.
It's far more spectrum than it is,
a binary, an all or
nothing, kind of a thinking.
So you can have optimal mental health
and still have experienced symptoms
of mental health challenges.
You can be living with them diagnosis
of serious mental illness
and have really great
positive, strong mental health.
So, the plot points on
that build quadrants,
really, I think how people see
that if you have a brain,
you have mental health
and your mental health
is gonna be impacted
in whatever goes on throughout your day.
In positive ways as Corey was saying,
and in not so positive ways.
And I think everybody being forced
to kind of live through this,
I hope, and it feels as if
there's a little bit of a groundswell
toward recognition that
it isn't us and them,
that we're all on that spectrum,
we're all within that continuum
of that framework.
And how it doesn't take much
to negatively impact your mental health
wherever you are at baseline,
whether it's living
with serious mental illness or not.
And I hope that that
has positively impacted
the space through,
by people understanding
how universal it really is.
- Right, it is.
I mean, 'cause it doesn't discriminate.
And I love that you use
the brain just saying it
'cause I just said this
in a speech somewhere.
It's like anybody that has a brain
has mental health.
And then there's the condition of it.
So I think about legal forms
that we have to fill out,
especially with divorces.
And one of the questions
is about your health.
What would you put?
Poor, good, excellent.
That's essentially what the surveys are.
And depending on what your numbers are
that could tell you whether you're mild
to severe and depression
or whatever it could be.
And I would love it
if we could just have this more openness
and it really does attribute to stigma.
Stigma, it seems like
as soon as you say the word mental,
we all pause, what are you gonna say next?
'Cause I'm not connecting with that word.
What are you gonna say?
But we have to understand,
people are so open to blurting out
what their physical conditions are,
the physical ailments and whatnot,
but not so much with the mental.
And so I say, okay,
just take mental and physical out of it.
I'm having some health complications.
Do we need to know us with your mind
or with some other part of your body?
No, that's between you and your doctor.
But what I am encouraging people,
the words of Bebe Moore Campbell,
she was a three-time,
New York Times bestselling author.
I claim her as my favorite author,
but she was a tremendous advocate
for NAMI in California
and started a chapter in Los Angeles
where she lived
because she was leaving her community
to go to a predominantly white area
to get the services from NAMI.
So she's now deceased,
but at the same time, she would say,
you need to get a checkup
from the neck up.
We go get our physicals.
Hopefully everybody goes once a year.
Why just stop here?
Like go up as well.
You can ask your doctor
for a mental health survey or inventory
or whatever they may call it.
And you can do that for
your children as well.
I was very, very pleased
with the pediatrician's office here,
when my son was younger,
they're both adults now.
And happy International Men's Day,
I must say,
I've never heard of that before.
I've heard that today.
- Me neither.
- I was gonna send both of my sons a text
and just saying, just to say hi.
- That works, that works.
- But anyway, they have them available
for children as well.
We can't say, oh, they're too young.
No, we have to be proactive.
Don't operate out of crisis,
don't wait until it gets to,
these behaviors being
okay, now something has
to be addressed here.
You don't have to get to that point,
be proactive.
When you go for your physicals,
ask for mental health inventory as well.
It doesn't mean that you have concerns,
but if it identifies something,
why not treat it?
Why not find out what you can do
to help yourself?
Versus waiting to like
gets to a bad, bad place,
which it could.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely agree.
Well, I was a neuroscientist
who studies the brain.
I agree with both of you
and I'm actually impressed
that you both brought
that up before I did.
I mean, it's critical,
I mean, to be honest,
I think as neuroscientists,
that's something we need
to do a lot better of
in terms of educating
the public and saying,
well, there are things are
going wrong in your brain
that's gonna have consequences.
I mean, we think about that
when we think about strokes
generally in society,
we don't think about that.
We think about things like
depression or anxiety,
because there are so many components
that can lead to those things,
but we tend to forget that
that happens through the brain.
Like these experiences that we have
impact our brains,
which impacts how we
approach these situations.
So, I mean, you're both
experts in my mind already.
But yeah, that's
something that I've shared
with audiences as well too.
Like if I, just based
on the things we study,
if I go and I increase
the levels of certain brain chemicals
in a certain way,
more than likely that can push you
into one direction or another
and lead to depression, or relate to that.
So, in the same way, I mean,
I always give the funny example.
If someone broke their arm,
they wouldn't just leave it
and say, oh, I'm just gonna kind of
get some counseling from my arm
or pray over my arm,
and then maybe it'll get better.
You go to the doctor, you get a cast.
But we do that with our
brains all the time.
irrespective of what type of experience
may have caused that change
in the brain to occur,
but we sometimes just leave it
and don't actually address it.
So I love that checkup from the neck up
and all those components.
- Doesn't our brain
control our whole body?
So we have to have it in optimum shape.
- And I think it is so
connected to stigma.
I think people don't think about it
as part of the brain or what,
because they don't want to deal with it,
they don't want it to
be happening to them,
it isn't real, it isn't true
if I just pretend to ignore it.
And we know that that doesn't work,
we know that that's not the case.
And I think when we think about stigma,
so often we think about,
creating a space where
people feel comfortable
coming out about what
they're going through.
And I think we also really need
to create a sense of inquiry
where we are actually feeling empowered
to say to someone who may seem like
things are not going so well.
To say, hey, are you okay?
I'm worried about you.
It's not enough to say,
well, we just have to create a world
where people feel
comfortable coming forward
and talking about it.
If you're living with
serious mental health issues,
you may not have the
ability to talk about it,
to come out and talk about it.
It's on the rest of us,
those other four
to find a way to say,
I'm worried about you, are you okay?
How can I help?
I think that's so important
if we're gonna really move
the needle on this
and kind of pull the curtain back.
- Yeah, yeah,
I definitely agree with you.
I think another layer on that too,
is just that the fear
that comes with that too,
and maybe that's also a fear of unknown.
Because when it comes to
the stigma, obviously,
but also our brains,
sometimes there's a fear of, well,
what is that going to entail?
And medication can be effective,
but medication isn't the only way
we change our brains.
So I mean, even things like meditation,
change our brains,
being in community, changes our brains.
I mean, I think at this point in time,
a lot of us have a better feel for that,
being in isolation,
something felt different
and that's because of the effects
that community has on our brains
and how it engages
certain reward pathways in our brains
that help us feel better
and go through our daily rhythms.
I mean, there's even studies looking at,
the power of prayer
and how that can impact the brain.
And counseling can impact
the brain, medication.
So, we have to have an approach
where we take all of
these different factors
and obviously I'm biased
and focusing on the brain.
But as Corey mentioned,
the brain does control our bodies,
so it's legitimate bias.
But just think about all
these different components
and ways that can
actually impact our brains
and how we interact with each other
and not being afraid to engage in those.
So I think, in a lot of ways,
as I'm talking out loud,
there's probably more that
we all should be doing
in partnerships with this.
With the advocacy work,
with the neuroscience,
to really bring these
types of conversations
to the forefront.
So people have a better understanding
and even try and move past the stigma
in that sense as well.
So just to give a story,
I had given a talk years back,
with the Public Library
that I called The
Neuroscience of Addiction,
just to kind of get a sense
and to help people understand
what happens when you have exposure
to certain substances for periods of time.
And so people from the
community came to that.
There were also a bunch of folks
from a recovery house,
that came to that as well.
And so that turned into
a really nice dialogue.
It wasn't just me there
kind of giving didactic information.
But I was sharing what
we knew about the brain,
they were also sharing
from their experience.
So in a sense, we both
learn from each other.
So a lot of the folks,
some of the folks walked in and said,
oh, well, I don't really
see this as an illness
because I did this to myself.
Which at some level is true,
you can't become addicted
if you've never used
a substance in the first place.
But by the end of the session,
they said, okay, well,
now I have a better understanding
of what my use has
actually done to my brain
and how the brain I have now
is not the same as it was before.
So it also gave them a sense of ownership
of ways to move forward,
to get to a new normal,
without being stuck in a,
this isn't an illness
and there's not much I can do about it.
So, I mean, I feel like
that was a really useful conversation
for both of us to be able to both sides,
to be able to get to a
better place of understanding
and also me as a scientist,
not just talking about those things
and not thinking about how
people are experiencing
some of the things they're going through,
whether it's with a medication,
or medication assisted treatments
and all those types of things.
So, 'cause I'm saying we need to have
more of what we're doing right here,
and it can really go a long way.
- And nutrition as well,
we often leave that out.
But the things we eat and drink,
just whatever we consume,
impacts our brain health
and overall physical health as well.
So we can make a lot of changes
just by being aware
of what we are putting into our mouths.
- And it's so empowering too,
to recognize that there are things over
which I actually have some control,
this isn't happening to me
in every way,
I can control my response to this.
And I think, well,
we have a group called Hearing Voices,
for voice hears,
people who hear voices
and some of them are on medication,
some of them are in
counseling and treatment,
some are doing both.
And some have said,
I don't want to take medication,
I can tolerate the voices,
it's manageable,
it's not having a negative impact
on my life right now,
and I'm okay with that.
So there's a level of autonomy
that people actually can have,
an agency and power
in how they're going to approach this.
There's not, again, it's not that
one size fits all
approach to getting well,
to doing better.
You have to pay attention
to what's going on for you
and really figure out what those,
to the extent you can figure out
what those pieces are
that are your holistic
approach to treatment.
Even through the lens of self care,
I feel like self-care sometimes
can feel so prescribed,
like it's meditating, yoga, or running.
Well, if you don't do any
of those three things,
you beat yourself up for not doing it
and then you're in this negative cycle
as opposed to self care,
you're doing self harm.
So like Corey was saying,
we tried to think about self-care as,
what do you need right now to be okay?
And maybe it is just sitting by the water,
and maybe it is yoga,
meditation or running,
maybe it's just crying
or looking out the window
at the leaves falling off of the trees.
It's excuse me.
We can play a part in moving that needle
and where we are by using the resources,
the tools, the supports that we have
to create that kind of wellness
approach for ourselves.
- Yeah, I definitely agree,
definitely awesome.
And I loved the examples too,
of just meeting people where they are.
Even as you're talking about,
some can tolerate the voices,
some don't want the voice
and just saying, well, what,
it goes back to a point
Corey is making as well.
I think Matt you're also making it.
Like, what do you need
to actually navigate the situation?
And that's a topic that came up
with the last case as well, Sean Astin
talking about his mom, Patty Duke,
and some of the challenges
with the language that was used
in terms of suffering versus navigating
and the fact that we can navigate
through these things
and still be at a place
of having overall health and
not great, kind of wellness in our lives,
even if there are some struggles
that are going on in the background.
And so, I mean, Matt,
you talked about the spectrum,
Corey, you talked about the spectrum.
Even if someone has a serious
mental health challenge,
but has navigated in a way
that's still effective.
We can't ignore that
and we can't put that in a box of,
oh, this is still bad.
Or someone who was on the,
we have to really just have
a broader perspective on these things
and help people navigate
and thrive in a lot of ways.
- And we don't hear those stories enough.
We hear so many stories
of people living with mental illness
who are not doing well,
or people who are committing crimes
or doing like wildly inappropriate,
awful things who we assume
are living with mental illness.
But we don't really hear stories
of people living with
serious mental illness
who are doing all right,
they're doing well.
There's so many ideas,
so many misconceptions around what,
who lives with mental illness
and what it means if you do.
And I think to normalize
the reality of it,
that recovery is real,
that you can live a rich, full life
with a diagnosis of mental illness,
serious mental illness.
We need to tell more of those stories
about people who are living well
and not focusing on sort of the negative
or assumed attributes
of who's living with mental illness.
- That's really well said.
And those assumptions can lead
to all sorts of,
often those aren't even correct.
And the ones that are
the minority of the cases
get blown up
and get the focus and the attention.
So I think it's really interesting.
- And just perpetuate the misunderstanding
and that contributes to the stigma
and that keeps people
who are living with these
issues in the shadows.
So it's just this negative cycle.
- Yeah, I mean, especially
like with the violence
that you talked about,
because the pervasive thought
is that people with mental illness
are more likely to commit
those types of crimes,
which is completely non-factual and false
because they're much
more likely to be victims
than to be the ones.
But if you talk to people
in the general public
has not the current
understanding of things,
even though it's completely incorrect.
- No, not at all.
And I think even further to that point,
we're assuming that,
like clearly someone who's committing
those kinds of acts of violence
are not doing well,
there's something going on for them.
But to just sort of label
them as mentally ill
is such a gross injustice,
it's not fair.
It's not fair to them,
it just shines the wrong light
on what these issues are
and who's living with them.
- Yeah, so as we wrap up,
I think we're also
touching on the many things
that we still have to do as a society.
So I'm curious, from both of you,
obviously the work that you're doing
is so important, is making a huge impact.
But what do you see as the next steps
that we need to make
either within your organizations
and your initiatives
or as a society in general?
Not a small question.
- Yes, not a small question,
and there is not a small answer.
But like we need an overhaul
to the mental health system.
It's too difficult to get help.
And I feel for those families
that don't have help
or don't know where to go for help,
which I'm trying to use my voice
as much as possible.
But also housing,
housing is one of the first things
that a person loses,
dealing with severe mental
illness, as an example,
because of the behaviors.
And they may be interpreted
as violating lease terms for example.
But having housing
available, quality housing,
I've seen some deplorable conditions
in group homes and things of that nature,
but they still get the full dollar
for an individual staying there.
So some of the things that I wanna work on
is just helping with legislation
that can help increase the quality of life
for those living with
sever mental illness,
as well as quality housing,
being available with the understanding
of behaviors and how they can just
have the opportunity to live in quality,
I can't stress that
enough quality housing,
with property owners that understand
the behaviors that may be exhibited
at any given time.
- Yeah, so well said.
- And NAMI NYC.
We're really focused on reaching
underserved communities right now.
And we're defining that
in pretty broad ways.
So, black and brown communities of course,
also deaf and hard of hearing communities,
the LGBTQ communities, older adults,
non native English speakers.
We really wanna make sure that,
the programs and services
that we're offering,
not only do all individuals
understand what they are
that they're free
and how easy it is to access,
but that they, again,
they feel seen when they show up,
when they come and they dip their toe
in the NAMI NYC water, so to speak.
And then we're also focusing
on the family piece,
the family caregiver piece.
We're continuing to provide programs
for people who are living
with mental illness
and we always will.
But one of the things we recognize is,
we're really the only resource
for family members,
especially family members of adults.
And so we wanna make sure
that families know that there's knowledge
and skill and support that you can learn
from our 40 year history
that can make a meaningful difference,
not only in your life
and in the life of the individual
who you care so much about,
but in your shared life.
So often we're winging it
and when we're winging it,
there's a tremendous amount of tension
and friction that tears families apart.
But it can be better,
it can be when we know
what to say, what not to say,
when to say,
and when not to say it,
how to say it, excuse me.
To separate the person
from their diagnosis
and their symptoms and see them separately
so that I can hate bipolar disorder,
but I love this person.
We're really focusing
on those family pieces as well.
And then as Corey mentioned, advocacy.
We can have all the programs
and services in the world,
but if we don't improve
the mental health system
and for us specific,
we're working on five tenants,
but the one I'll call out today
is decriminalizing mental illness.
It's so critically important
for us to really move the system,
to change the mental health system
so that it really can be
mental health for all.
- Yes, well said.
- Well, that wasn't an easy question,
but I definitely appreciate
both of the answers
that you both mentioned.
And I encourage listeners too,
to just reach out to
your local NAMI as well,
if there are things,
resources you're looking for
or ways get involved and to support.
And Corey, even as you mentioned,
with the housing.
Any specific suggestions,
Corey for listeners in terms of,
ways that they may be able to get involved
in some of these fights
from a legal perspective.
- Yes, contacting their
local representatives,
state representatives,
as well as their federal legislators
and finding out NAMI is very good,
it has an advocacy piece on their website
where it tells you about
pending legislation
and how to communicate
with your Congress member.
And it's just important for us to know
that these things are important.
The emails, the phone call,
they are important.
So we may not think
we're making a big impact
because it's just one phone call from us,
but you can get your family and friends
to do it as well.
And if there's ever a hearing
that you can go and sit in
and even be able to speak,
I suggest you please let people know
that you are willing to do that and share
how important some of these
pieces of legislation are.
Especially with the exclusion,
I'm sure you can give me the,
is it the IMD exclusion for the beds?
There's like a limit on the number of beds
that are available in order for a refund
to occur to that local entity.
And so, it's just unfortunate
that it's all about money
when you have real lives
that are being impacted
and need the services.
So, I just encourage individuals
to go to organization's websites,
like NAMI, like Mental Health America,
like the Treatment Advocacy Center
and look at their legislation
and policy and procedure piece
because they have so many
things already in place,
templates you can use,
they help you to be able to communicate
with legislators who can make a difference
and the time is now to
make that difference.
- That's great advice.
Well, thanks so much to
both of you for the time,
taking the time out to join the Addy Hour,
for sharing all these wealth of resources
with our listeners and
sharing your experiences
and your advocacy as well.
Definitely appreciate
your time and the work
that you all do
and I think we'll have to follow up
and continue this
conversation at some point.
- Thank you, thank you for having me,
I really appreciate it.
And I do wanna share
also with your listeners
that they can go to coreyempowers.com.
I put together my go-to
mental health guide.
And again, me just coming in raw with this
and just wanting to learn all I can,
but it has movies and books, blogs, apps,
just different things that you can go to
at your leisure to find out more.
If it's someone you're dating,
someone you're married to,
or a family member or your child,
or yourself, and you wanna know more,
please look into it.
Don't just try to ignore things
because more than likely,
it's not gonna go away.
Find out what you can do now,
find out more about
treatments that are available
and resources that are available as well.
So that's at coreyempowers.com,
my go-to mental health guide.
- Really important,
and I'm so grateful,
you've put that together.
- Yes, thank you.
- Yeah, it's great to be here.
It's such a pleasure to
get to know you Corey
and hear about all the amazing things
you're working on.
- Yes, it's a pleasure
to meet you as well Matt
and I look forward to
staying in touch with you.
- Likewise.
- Excellent, thanks to both of you again.
(upbeat music)